so it seems like a good point to bring
us all together now you might have
noticed you're like you started to march
through just like you did before and
then you're like what Oh some things
have gone wrong right because you looked
at this and treated it much like the
previous object I mean it does look very
similar right you're like oh cool I can
read the UM I can read the intercepts
the x-intercepts off of this right
what's the x-intercept you get out of
this one what's the x-intercept you get
out of this negative three and then
you're like oh last time I got three
this time I've only got two so a lot of
people now this is actually really
important because at least four people
independently have done this so I want
to call your attention because this is
really a big red flag for me okay a lot
of people have said to me oh I know what
to do with this please don't write this
down it's equal to this now what a lot
of people are thinking of in their mind
is something different you're thinking
of this that's the difference of two
squares okay now this is really
different and I just want to pause for a
minute
not to teach you something but just to
point out how easy it is to mistake one
for the other and how important is fine
like that's a background skill that's a
background skill right mrs. Lee's
mmm okay now let's convince ourselves
that this is not really what's going on
right number one number one this X minus
one all squared does I hope it looks
different 2x minus x squared minus one
right the the thing that's being squared
is quite different in addition to that
like when you say something squared
what you mean is something multiplied by
itself right so actually the correct
like if you wanted to break it apart a
little more the correct way to write
this would be so I need to drop some
stuff on yeah that's right it's not an X
minus one and an X plus one it's an X
minus one and then it's another X minus
one right now writing it in this way is
actually helpful for us because it draws
out something a bit weird which is that
remember how we said oh there's a root
on one and negative 3/2 said an x
intercept right when we write it in this
way it kind of makes it look like wait a
second it's like there's two on one
right and then there's this other one or
negative three so it's like there's two
roots but they're on the same spot okay
rusty um question if you multiply these
together you'd get this but that's just
kind of going back where we started
right okay so you could if you wanted
you could expand that right that would
give you x squared minus two X minus
three
but then what you would say is our minds
will kind of factorize that all over
again because the factorized form is
what's useful to us right so expanding
it doesn't end up getting us anywhere
useful well not many places yes you'd
get this
x squared minus 2x plus 1 that's what
you'd get but then what do I do with
that it's gonna be just like this one
it's good it's gonna go back here
there's no other way you can there's not
a simple way you can write it that's
kind of like tying up a knot and then
untying it it's like my shoe is still on
my foot okay my socks work anyway okay
whatever right
yeah we need to bring this back to this
graph right what does it actually look
like well I'm gonna put on the
information that you've just told me
right there's the one here I'm gonna be
a bit little little weird and I'm
actually going to put another X there to
indicate there's something weird
happening here and then there's negative
3 1 2 3 look like so ok now what's it
going to look like ok now you can
actually try this out you can put some
values in I should ask by the way just
like before is it one of these or is it
one of these positive or negative it's
positive because there's no minus signs
on the x's so it's going to be this guy
right and so when you have a look at
this shape right you're actually going
to pass through at negative 3 then
you're gonna go up come down and then
instead of going right through you can't
pierce through the axis because then you
have to come back up somewhere else but
did you notice there is no somewhere
else did you notice that if I would have
found other x-intercepts I would found
them here right but I have to actually
touch and then leave back off this does
look just like what we were drawing
before just it's a little bit higher see
that the first one we did this morning
was y equals x cubed right y equals x
cubed have a look at it for me how many
x-intercept does it have
you could either say you could say
there's one it's right there yeah
or being that x-cubed you could write
that as X times X times X it's like
there's a root zero here and here and
here it's almost like there's three
roots all sitting on top of each other
there so the number of roots that you
have actually changes the behavior a
little bit this is actually what we call
a double root but we'll go into that in
a little more detail later on this is
the shape it's a bit messy but I don't
care why not because it's just a sketch
in order to solve the real question okay
the real question is when is this lesser
than or equal to zero can you tell me
where Kon Tomi what do you reckon yeah
good to the left of three this guy's
good right do I include negative three I
do how did you know it's included the
boundaries so I'm just gonna do a nice
of that circle that is there another
spot where you recommend where it
touches the x-axis and touches exactly
the right word right by the way it's
tangent to the axis right here
do we think what's the value by the way
what is the value here x equals that's
it's one right the Y value is zero and I
think that helps answer like if is that
part included is it less than or equal
to zero and the answer is it's equal
it's exactly equal so this guy is okay
right so you're ready to actually
express our answer now right we've done
everything on the graph so I'm ready to
actually provide an answer inequality
let's go for it I'm gonna go from left
to right like I usually do
so this part here is negative three how
do I say to the left of negative three
X is less than or equal to negative
three okay with that is anything else do
we include anything else or X exactly
equals one because it's not less than or
equal to it's only that right spot
exactly there okay now for this next
part here we do this in interval
notation okay we know how to do this
part here right I have to go from left
to right until the full notation so
where do I begin
negative infinity which means do I use a
parenthesis or a square bracket the
square bracket means I can get there
which I don't have any on the board off
that have written yet okay but I can't
get to negative infinity can I so
therefore it's a parentheses comma where
do I go up until negative three do I
include this I do so it's a square
bracket and then here's the wee bit
misses these and I were having this
conversation right I think the best way
to write this the least ambiguous way is
to say well this next interval right
where does it start
one where does it end is that okay and
of course I have my square brackets
because I have to include the start and
end point which are both one okay last
little bit shall we do this number line
should we do it you'd get rid of all
this other stuff it's all gone
say it again yeah I'm sorry about that
you can draw another one although I
should point out I always graph in
pencil partly because my graphs are
generally so terrible that I need to fix
them up along the way and I encourage
you I think pencil is a good way to go
with that okay so here is my less than
negative three and there's my one BAM
it's finished okay um quick question did
anyone do this one yet good because I
want to make a minor change too
okay there we go
right so this one says two minus X
that's messy I'll write it again two
minus X and then in the other brackets
it says x squared minus X minus 1
greater than worker zero okay right what
does this thing look like well I'm gonna
prepare myself my Cartesian plane one
last time this is gonna be the last
example that we do together
you don't pretty well said again sorry
okay epsilon epsilon yeah there we go
okay I'm looking for some x-intercepts
I've been searching x-intercepts are
always the thing that I start with so
can someone tell me what x-intercept
will I get from here to is correct - now
you'll notice I've been a slightly rude
and giving you this thing here which is
not neatly factorized and so I'm gonna
ask you what routes could we get out of
x squared minus X minus 1 we could go to
the quadratic formula ty I'm trying to
make you work what am i doing the rest
of this time okay I could go to the
quadratic formula for this right I'm
just gonna write the first line of the
quadratic formula - B are you okay with
that plus or minus the square root of a
horn a second I'll do it wrong I did do
it wrong sorry
that's what I meant to do it's a it was
too easy too easy
no no no he's right yeah I did a
register okay
- BAE plus or minus the square root of
what's B squared in this case
minus 4ac which in this case is for do
you agree with that and then I divide by
2a what are the siliceous to this thing
there aren't any there are this here
this is why I got a sign wrong okay
there are no siliceous to this thing so
what does this mean well we started off
we did we have seen so far you can get
cubics which have three solutions we
started off with that this lesson this
one had two solutions right
we knew this guy had one solution right
well how many solutions have I found to
you how many exorcisms just the one at
two and then this other guy did not give
us anything
what a jerk okay all right my next
question is this going to be one of
these or one of these it's the second
one how could you tell good there's a
minus there and then that's the only
minus sign yeah so a single minus sign
will become negative right it is sad
right so therefore my shape is gonna
look like that and I'm only allowed to
hit the x-axis here you see that well
it's still gonna be a cubic well I
missed you get the idea but I'm not
allowed to hit the x-axis in any other
places except the one I already
identified do you see that it is
forbidden okay a way you can think about
this if you like why they no solutions
well if I wanted to get more excerpts
right I would had to have found them
from here yeah well if it'd be positive
it might look like this like that it
might have looked like that but again
I'm still allowed to touch the x-axis
anywhere else are you okay with that I
can touch the x-axis anywhere else
because I would have found those
x-intercepts earlier and I've already
ruled them out too is the only one
you're allowed to have okay now will
point out because I've done no other
work than to find the x-intercepts I
actually don't know whether the graph
looks like that
or like this sorry this is messy too
right
you know how these cubics right sorry
these cubics they had this like weird
like wobbly bit this sort of kink in the
middle okay I don't know where the King
comes before the to or after but why do
you think I don't care no tell you I can
share that's just how I roll
right